i like watching some of the things i
like watching sometimes like in brazil
or wherever it might be
uh somebody tries to rob the wrong
person and that person
happens to have a piece on them and it's
trained world star has that but they're
not even trained
they try it's like some punk tries
robbing a dude like he tried carjacking
him with a gun this just
just a dad with these these three black
dudes rolled up on him tried jacking his
like g-wagon or something
they have the gun on his face and he
gets that car like this and then
probably been watching so much [ __ ]
john wick or something he's like
yeah it's the gun what then picks the
kid up
spikes him on his head and his buddies
just take off and you can see him like
teach him a lesson like he obviously
wasn't gonna shoot and we just teach him
a lesson oh that's crazy yeah
it's so funny he brought that up this
just happened on melrose melrose
shootout
yeah so just so you guys know you know
if you don't live in la so
melrose there's a group of guys that
they they see
you pull up to the restaurant stuff and
everyone's eating outside right now so
you pop the restaurants and
whatever your g-wag your mercedes your
porsche's ferraris and they look at your
watches and stuff like that then they
just wait for you to leave
and then they're robbing people like all
the time oh this happened in beverly
hills
that's the same group oh it's the same
group melrose beverly hills the same
group doing it
wow guys yeah let me see this pick the
wrong guy but then look what happens
when uh
at the end of it he's talking to two
girls here in the state of our newsroom
out of an attempted robbery that ended
with bullets flying this happening just
after seven o'clock last night
near melrose and white hornets standing
there talking in a parking lot when the
dodge avenger pulls up
two men get out one of them brandishing
a gun then the victim of the robbery
pulls out
himself opens fire on those would-be
robbers oh [ __ ] and that's why you
should carry kids
i agree with x who got out of the car he
got shot right he shot the guy in the
stomach
he did he hit him but two of them got uh
gun shot
one to the thigh and then one two oh
that guy kept firing yeah wow
so this dude's a bad [ __ ] that's
number two i just carry a gun though
yeah but now now does he get booked for
anything that's the thing yeah i don't
know because
he had it like here yeah let me see this
again but the problem is this kid pulls
a gun up i love this well look at this
bad [ __ ]
watch this it all depends you [ __ ]
the wrong dude
this is self-defense definitely
self-defense the guy gets that well if
he has a
license he doesn't have a permit even
then though the prosecutor might not
give you a hard time here
watch this
pulls a gun himself oh he got that he
got that guy in the leg damn dude
this is a great reason why you should
carry he just went whoop bang bang
wow the police later arrest the two
suspects fled on foot
fighting it far well i i need
this really does make me want to carry
something on my hip
you understand correct i mean in your
car yes right now the times are wild
yeah
otherwise you're sitting down especially
where you're at on the west when i go
the west side
you got to have a piece especially at
night you must be
you must be ready at all times you guys
can probably get one easily
i mean i haven't i have one no no a perm
i got a problem i have a permit yeah
yeah i carry yeah i carry at all times
oh yeah i didn't know that
yeah i don't want to [ __ ] yeah once [ __ ]
started popping off on the west side and
me and chin have to go down there and
[ __ ] podcasts and everything was
boarded up i was like god yeah
i guess dude i need my though those were
dicey times remember chin
oh we boarded up the walls i mean what's
crazy is when they looted and destroyed
everything they didn't touch
ours i like to think the looters went we
like that guy we like and then kept
going
it's so tempting to our building dude
it's so attached mirror glass all over
the place
and then if they start and if they knew
anything it's like dude there's so much
there's thousands and thousands of
elections oh what are you gonna do let's
let's podcast now we can podcast no no
they steal the laptop come on bro
the laptops the cameras like this is all
going for thousands of dollars yeah
that's the move yeah they really [ __ ]
up
no they didn't they did a good job oh
yeah thank god thanks for being fans of
the show